lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
asegurarme de que realmente entienden lo
que pasa cuando hacemos una llamada a la
función fibonacci recursiva así que voy
a asumir que alguien llama la función
con un argumento digamos fibonacci de 5
no lo voy a hacer con un argumento muy
grande porque si no me quedaría
explicando esto para siempre
tratemos con fibonacci de 5 en esta
situación en el contexto de esta función
el parámetro n que tenemos aquí va a ser
igual a 5 en la primera pasada el
parámetro va a ser igual a 5 y aquí
decimos si en es menor que 2
definitivamente cinco no es menor que 2
así que nos vamos a la cláusula else a
la segunda parte de la condición f y
vice returns fibonacci de n
1 + fibonacci de n menos dos entonces
esto que tenemos aquí va a ser igual que
decidir fibonacci de 4 recuerden que en
es igual a 5 menos uno es igual a 4
fibonacci de 4 + fibonacci de n
2 y cuando corrimos la función aquí en
es igual a 5 así que decimos fibonacci
de 3 y bueno aquí tenemos más llamadas a
la función tenemos que hacerlo de nuevo
pero ahora n95 sino que es 4 y 3
probemos con esto aquí en es igual a 4
y que 4 no es menor que 2 y no hacemos
esta parte sino que nos vamos a la
cláusula else y esto se va a descomponer
en fibonacci de 3 porque n es 44 menos
uno es igual a 3 + fibonacci de cuatro
menos 2 que es 2 así que estoy aquí
esencialmente nos va a regresar
estas dos llamadas a la función y esto
de la derecha fibonacci de 3 n ahora es
3 lo voy a hacer en verde 3 no es menor
que 2 así que sigo acá abajo fibonacci
de 3 - 1 sí bonacci de 2 + fibonacci de
3 - 2 osea fibonacci de 1 y después
venimos a esta parte y calculamos cada
una de estas cosas lo que significa más
llamadas a la función fibonacci y
fibonacci de 3 como pueden ver esto se
está haciendo muy grande así que voy a
empezar a escribir fin en lugar de
fibonacci y tenemos fibonacci de 3
es no es menor que 2 hacemos la cláusula
else fibonacci de tres menos uno es ibón
hd2 fib de dos más y bonacci de 3 - 2 fi
de uno y por acá tenemos fibonacci de 22
no es menor que 2 así que hacemos y
bueno aquí de 2 - 1 sí bonacci de 1 +
fibonacci de 2 menos dos más fibonacci
de cero tenemos que éste fibonacci de 2
se descompone en estas dos llamadas a la
función y de este lado tenemos fibonacci
de 2 la misma cosa así que se va a
descomponer en lo mismo que vimos con
esta llamada la función fibonacci de 1 +
fibonacci de 0 y ahora tenemos fibonacci
de 1 y esto se pone interesante porque
cuando n es igual a 1 este código de
aquí se vuelve relevante porque ahora n
es menor que 2 y nos regresa n entonces
esto de aquí se va a simplificar como a
1 este término es igual a 1 va a ser
evaluado como 1
y luego vamos a ver lo que está aquí
abajo fibonacci de dos sabemos que
fibonacci de dos se evalúa como
fibonacci de uno mas fibonacci de cero
dejen escribirlo aqui fibonacci de uno
mas fibonacci de cero recuerden que
estamos usando feef como una forma corta
de fibonacci y luego sabemos que
fibonacci de uno es menor que dos así
que nos va a regresar n que es igual a 1
fibonacci de 1 nos regresa 1 sí bonacci
de 0 0 es menor que 2 así que nos
regresa a 0 si bonacci de 0 es 0
fibonacci de 1 nos regresa 1 fibonacci
de 0 nos regresa a 0 y luego fibonacci
de 1 nos regresa a uno y fibonacci de 0
nos regresa a 0 todas las veces que el
intérprete procesa estas llamadas a la
función fibonacci tiene que recordar de
donde fue llamada porque en algún
momento tiene que llegar a los casos
básicos y la función va a regresar
valores numéricos en ese momento y tiene
que reconstruir las llamadas que se
hicieron antes así que fibonacci
2 es 10 y se simplifica como 1 se
simplifica como uno luego fibonacci de 3
es igual a fibonacci de 2 + fibonacci de
1 que se simplifica como 11 fibonacci de
3 es igual a 2 y nos pasamos para acá
fibonacci de 2 es igual a 1 + 0 es igual
a 1 si bonacci de 2 es 10 es igual a 1
fibonacci de 1 ya habíamos visto que es
1 y ahora vamos a este nivel tenemos que
reconstruir las llamadas a la función
hasta que lleguemos a la llamada
original y no vamos a hablar de los
detalles de como el intérprete hace las
llamadas a la función que es una
discusión emocionante solo queremos ver
que esto funciona y queremos ver por qué
nos regresa a las respuestas correctas y
luego vamos a fibonacci de 4 el cuarto
término de la sucesión de fibonacci es
la suma del tercer término y del segundo
podemos tratar de imaginar lo es este 2
+
de 1 fibonacci de 4 se evalúa como 3 el
tercer término de fibonacci es por la
definición de la sucesión de fibonacci
la suma del segundo término más el
primer término y aquí tenemos uno más
uno es 2 lo simplificamos como 2 y el
quinto término de la sucesión de
fibonacci es la suma del cuarto término
más el tercer término o sea tres más dos
así que este término de aquí va a ser
evaluado como 5
espero que esto les haya aclarado un
poco la manera en que funciona este
ejemplo recursivo de fibonacci lo que es
importante saber es que no funcionaría
si no definimos casos básicos como
fibonacci de uno y fibonacci de cero
porque si no se mantendría llamando a la
función para siempre sin llegar a ningún
lado así que la clave de la recursividad
es que se llama a sí misma hasta llegar
a los casos básicos cada vez que se
llama debe acercarse más al caso básico
se sigue llamando una vez más y más
hasta que llega en algún momento al caso
básico y se reconstruye hasta la llamada
original por eso funciona cada llamada a
la función fibonacci es una nueva
versión con un valor de n menor cada vez
hasta que lleguemos al caso básico que
nos regresa valores numéricos y entonces
podemos reconstruir hasta la llamada
original bueno espero que esto les haya
ayudado la recursividad puede ser un
poco complicada pero a la vez es algo
así como elegante y hermosa